wow that overlong tweet thread sent me
to a website I've never used before
sorry who the do you think you are hi
you really think you're in a wals in
here and look at our video with an ad
blocker on oh yeah I I forgot it was on
oh you forgot it was on I'm going to
tell you exactly what you're going to do
you're going to pause it refresh the
page and then maybe maybe I will let you
look at our article sorry what was that
I'm sorry oh hi hi yeah hi our team here
just happened to notice that you're
you're actually um you're using an ad
blocker we rely on ads to support our
website so you could pause the ad
blocker if you don't mind or you could
um you know continue on to the website
without supporting us you could just
walk right in acknowledging to our faces
that you don't want to support us wait
wait wait please feel bad about it
though